[Música]
normandía sus acantilados de tiza Blanca
sus volcajes verdes y sus productos
locales ocupando un lugar especial por
supuesto la sidra de normandía guión
capelle es productor de sidra campesina
desde hace 10 años para él todo empieza
en estos vergeles con un sabio
equilibrio para reunir las diferentes
variedades de los diferentes manzanos
respetando los antiguos esto es del
Antiguo propietario quien tenía una
variedad con equilibrio muy bueno
entonces reproducimos escrúpulosamente
son diferentes manzanas estamos hablando
de una decena de variedades de manzanas
no se usan productos químicos para
hacerle mantenimiento a estas 20
hectáreas de manzanos guión tuvo que
adaptarse a los Caprichos de la
naturaleza estos vergeles el año pasado
fue dramático los 15 días de viento del
noreste chamoscocas y todo me la pasé
dos días recogiendo casi cuatro
toneladas con mi máquina donde debería
haber hecho unas 50 o 60 toneladas guión
se diversificó con sus manzanas produce
otro elixir emblemático de normandía El
calvados esta mañana flotan 12 vapores
alcoholizados un destilador de cosecha
ambulante destila el aguardiente de
guillón
[Música]
por ahora quema las papilas más que otra
cosa
por eso tomé un vaso tipo degustación
para probar con la nariz más que
de cualquier forma lo que se olería son
los defectos y los hubiese
y hay defectos
no está bien De todas formas no le diría
lo contrario para ser perfecto el
calvado de guillón tendrá que envejecer
en estos barriles de Roble durante tres
años como mínimo
tal como su sidra es una historia de
paciencia Y exigencia
estoy convencido de que si uno no se
rompe la cabeza elaborando un producto
si uno no se exige no puede valorizarlo
como se debe si hacemos sidra coca-cola
no podremos vender la más cara que la
coca-cola
lejos de los vergeles de manzanas
normandía también es tradición de pesca
aún hoy más de seiscientas embarcaciones
de pesca recorren las costas de la
Mancha en
Mary y su equipo se preparan para salir
al mar de costumbre pescan la concha San
Jack el oro blanco de normandía pero en
esta temporada esperan traer pescado
la red de arrastre Es verdaderamente
suerte la concha uno sabe lo que va a
traer según los sectores permanecen ahí
nos vemos volvemos seguirá ahí
recorre las aguas normandas desde hace
10 años como pescador profesional se
siente muy bien comandando su
embarcación
es mejor que en una oficina
la libertad esta embarcación es el
orgullo de Pierre la hizo construir hace
tres años y hace que una decena de
personas vivan de su trabajo un sueño de
infancia para este joven empresario así
Al principio haya sido un poco movido
vomité durante dos años luego dejó de
ocurrir
es un poco maso
De todas formas es el único oficio en el
que se puede ganar dinero sin ir mucho a
la escuela entre la escuela y el trabajo
yo elegí rápido a Los Pescadores Se les
paga en función de lo que pescan y la
competencia en las aguas de la mancha es
feroz los ingleses cuando están aquí hay
que hacer las cosas rápido porque tienen
unidades tres a cuatro veces más grandes
que la mía Entonces es una guerra
mientras Los Pescadores regresan al
puerto en el bosque cercano llega la
hora a la que Pierre saca sus vacas
normandas
pasan nueve meses al año en estos
pastizales del parque de contento una
zona límite que era uno de los pantanos
más grandes de Europa resultado el suelo
es muy fértil
hay una 100 especies vegetales en la
misma Pradera hay gramíneas leguminosas
plantas medicinales etcétera les es
suficiente como alimento
las vacas de Pierre producen diariamente
1200 litros de leche orgánica
quiere probar
Está buena una parte de esta leche
servirá para fabricar la famosa
mantequilla normanda
mucho sabor y además es muy fácil de
transformar con un muy buen olor
una mantequilla muy amarilla que ha
construido la reputación del pueblo
Normando de isiñe desde el siglo 17 y en
1934 en esta fábrica surge la idea de
transformar el excedente de leche en
caramelo
desde entonces el caramelo de insignia
es apreciado mundialmente y la receta no
ha cambiado
mantequilla azúcar leche y crema
solo ingredientes locales mezclados en
estos túneles a 125 grados
después de ser enfriado el caramelo es
formado a mano cortado y empacado
mantequilla suave o salada en el
calvados existen 25 variedades
es nuestra región es muy rico esto se
pega en los dientes
el caramelo de insignia no se puede
disociar de normandía Tal como tantos
otros productos locales fruto del
esfuerzo de estos Pescadores y pequeños
productores y del saber hacer de
normandía
[Música]